this is Graham kch with New Media rock
stars we are coming to you from the
YouTube space LA tonight we are
celebrating the Fine Brothers 1 million
views party the intelligent Olga K I'm
here because I want to have with the
Fine Brothers have a billion views oh
gosh don't we all want to have that we
all do all of us so what I'm going to do
is show you some video clips of myself
as a Russian I would choose sexy first
because I just want to see what you're
working with
I feel like I want to dislike it because
I didn't see any you like
hey so I think for the next time you
should maybe Reveal Your Shoulder a
little bit record me following your
directions that was a 6C video of you
sat there with your top kind of like
lowly down and kind of weird to be
honest so but dude I think dancing might
be your Forte excellent excellent Trisha
hburg I'm going to show you some video
footage of me wait are you naked well
I'm going to go with this one because I
feel like that's a very Tyler Oakley
thumb all right here we go oh look at
that is that the Single Ladies dance do
you have any suggestions for me to
adjust any of them were you ever in like
an eating contest or anything oh look
Porto all right here we go food
challenge it's on I believe in you eat
that cheese ball get it get it eat that
b b you got this guys that's a real
YouTube Star right there I'm standing
here with the one and only Felicia Day
now how could I get that from say
hundreds of views to a billion views you
could maybe do it
naked I would just say maybe show your
special skills off if you have any if
you don't it's I mean I'm not judging
you we've kind of reached this insane
plateau of how is it possible that uh we
could be here with this many views and
subscribers it's mindboggling and what
is the beautiful thing about it is we
also get here from collaboration a
collaboration collab collab collab
collab who else is
famous I'm here with Josh and Diego I
have some videos for you to watch I mean
I already love this oh wow those moves
those you have good moves the knees it
really it any adjustments you might give
me to make that from say 10 views to
million sleep with the right people take
all your clothes off and jump Cuts there
you have it I'm here with Joseph Eleanor
Nation I have some videos I'd like you
to
see all right I first I want to say how
does that not have a billion views I
would watch that every day in my life
any adjustments you might give me well I
think towards the end you should
annotate your nipples and now we can
annotate it thank God so now I'd like to
send you guys my viewers all 1 million
and one of you to the video that we have
compiled
here we go collab collab collab you eat
it all you're going to be famous don't
you jump
cut collap over the shoulder and then
blow a kiss twk it twk it Twerk It Twerk
It TW itwi
mus
nice I've had a wonderful time at the
Fine Brothers 1 billion views party we
wish them all the best and future
success and possibly 1 trillion views
now please go to subscribe to New Media
rock stars like this video and give me
your advice in the comments below please
be kind I'm a delicate flower you do not
want to see me wither before your eyes
unless that gets me 1 billion views huh